[Music]
if you were a TV junkie like me you're
probably very excited about this one of
my favorite shows the Americans had its
season premiere last week I don't know I
just watched it last night it was
fantastic yeah Americans is great and
from what I've heard season four is
gonna be just amazing I'm sorry who just
said ha twas I who just said ha and it
will be me who says ha again right now
ye saying ha because your pathetic
little show the Americans will soon be
incinerated by the roaring fires of
another much better show okay based on
how your dress I can probably guess what
show you're talking about show a brave
warriors fight for the other of their
family in a realm of magic yes now we
all know the so here the howling of the
icy winds Conan something is coming and
it starts with a w yes yes yes winter is
coming yes sir
nay I am speaking of wool burgers wall
burgers the the reality show about Mark
Wahlberg's family running a burger joint
in Boston is the very same of all the
epic tales that spring forth from the
mystifying story box known as the
television it Stokes my fame can't wait
a minute
I'm sorry I don't watch it is it a good
show oh it's well done just like some of
the burgers they cook on the show yeah
that's funny Joe but sometimes it can be
very cheesy just like some of the
burgers they cook on the show yeah and
sometimes sometimes the show's plot
involves a bit of a pickle
just like the game okay sorry
tomato listen sir I am sorry but wall
burgers just doesn't sound like the kind
of show that I would watch all right all
right I know what will convince you
let's read an actual scene from the show
tonight well you know what I'd love to
but I can't cuz I don't have a script
Brad we'll bring you a strip steak who's
Brad he scratched me Brad likes you all
right shut up okay you know once again
we're going to read this scene together
this is a word-for-word real scene from
wall burgers season 4 episode 3 you're
going to play chef Paul Wahlberg and
I'll play his assistant Carey now the
scene opens in the kitchen as Paul is
slaving over the grill that's you and si
so I'm working on the burger for Robert
Kraft the owner of the New England
Patriots it's gonna be special from what
I'm gathering this is gonna go in front
of Robert Kraft whoa that's yeah I don't
want to disrespect mr. Kraft bacon is
always a good idea and see
take a bow Conan
[Applause]
from the photos thank you very much
we'll be right back Chris Hardwick is
here
you